estas imágenes se remontan a 1935 y la
ciudad de París ha prometido hacer la
realidad de nuevo
nuevamente los nadadores utilizarán las
aguas del río sena para competir en los
Juegos Olímpicos de 2024
tendremos maratón de natación y triatlón
para los Juegos Olímpicos y paralímpicos
en el sena es vena ha sido un proyecto
durante décadas Y eso es para mí una
demostración fantástica del poder de los
juegos
para alcanzar su objetivo los
funcionarios se han centrado en las
casas ribereñas y los barcos que habían
estado tirando sus aguas residuales y
les han pedido que se conecten a la red
de alcantarillado también han invertido
más de 500 millones de euros en
infraestructura
Contamos con una instalación de
almacenamiento que puede tomar hasta
unos 50.000 metros cúbicos de agua
equivalente a 20 piscinas olímpicas que
nos permitirán contener el agua de
lluvia para evitar que las alcantarillas
se desborden Y luego el agua que se
almacena aquí Se volverá a tratar
progresivamente una vez que deje de
llover para evitar que se contamine el
sena la ciudad dice que sus esfuerzos ya
están dando frutos con la aparición de
más especies de peces y el mejoramiento
en la calidad del agua en algunas áreas
Incluso si no es cristalina
francamente si tomara una medida Y viera
que es buena saltaría y nadaría de
inmediato
los funcionarios esperan que todos los
parisinos puedan nadar en el futuro en
su emblemático río por lo que estudian
cinco lugares para abrirlos al público
un año después de los juegos en 2025